I'm going to show you how I would start
day trading over as a complete beginner
if I had to start over from scratch. I
wasted over five years trying to learn
how to trade and thousands of dollars
wasted losing trades over and over till
now I'm consistently making money and
I'm making over $1,000 in one single
trade only taking 90 minutes a day. So,
I'm going to start by giving you the
knowledge you need to understand
markets, why they move, and how you can
profit from those moves. I'm going to
give you the tools and websites you need
to get started trading, plus a plan for
you moving forwards on how you can
accelerate your trading learning curve
as fast as possible. Now, first off,
let's look at a simple stock chart. The
whole reason why price goes up and down
is all because of supply and demand. As
the price of any chart you're looking at
goes up, that means there is a higher
demand for that current asset. And then
if it slows down or starts to go down,
that means there is less demand and an
increase in supply. And so this is what
makes markets go up and down is
essentially there's more demand than
there's supply. And so people are
willing to pay a higher price for it
versus when people don't want it as
much. Well, they're willing to buy it
for cheaper and cheaper and sell it for
cheaper and cheaper, which also pushes
the price down. To give you a more
robust example, if we take a market,
let's say a stock of Apple and it's
trading at a range between $100 and
$110. Well, you as a trader of Apple,
when Apple is down at $100, you really
like that price because you think well
from $100, you think it's going to go up
a ton from there. And so what do you do?
You buy a bunch of Apple stock and
shares and you, you know, sit and wait
and as more people think that because
it's at a low price, well, it goes up in
value. And so what continues it higher
is even at 105, people still think, hey,
I think it's going to go up higher and
so I still want to buy it at this price
and thus pushing the price up even more.
And so let's say when it comes up to 110
a share, you think that, well, it's a
little overpriced and I'd rather sell it
and now get $110 for what I bought
before. And you know, maybe there's a
bunch of other investors and traders
thinking this. And so that's how it
starts to shift where, you know, maybe
it start doesn't go up in its uptrend
anymore. It starts to go sideways
because the demand and supply is
starting to become in more of an
equilibrium. That's what makes a market
or a chart of an asset start to go
sideways is there's an equilibrium in
the supply and demand. Now, let's say
the Apple earnings come out and it's
really bad and that would reduce the
demand for Apple and it would make the
stock plummet because people would say,
"Hey, it's overvalued. I don't want to
buy it at that price." And so, people
are now trying to get rid of it. But
they have to keep undercutting each
other because nobody wants to buy it at
that price. That's how a chart can drop
so quickly is because there is such a
gap between where someone wants to sell
it and someone will be willing to buy
it. All of this back and forth and
supply and demand creates buying
opportunities for us as traders. We're
able to see where are these supply and
demand zones and trade based on that.
when it comes down to let's say a demand
zone we say hey it is undervalued and
I'm going to buy it and you're able to
profit on that move up that is the whole
way that as trading you take advantage
of moves up and moves down in the market
whereas investing you're generally just
holding it and hoping it goes up over
time and the long term if we look at the
whole goal of trading versus investing
they have a lot of differences if you
look at let's say investing ing $1,000.
Over time, if you're putting it in the
S&P 500, you're going to get an average
of 10% 11% historically. The last 20
years has been pretty good and you've
you've been able to get a little bit
higher, but generally what you're going
to do if you invested $1,000, every year
you're going to get, you know, 10%
return. So, after a year of investing
$1,000, you get $100. Now, when it comes
to trading, things are a lot different.
If you take trading $1,000, well,
generally you don't put up your whole
account on one single trade, what you do
is you invest a portion of it, let's say
5 or 10%, and you place that on one
trade. And for one single trade, for a
quick example, you can take $100 on a
smaller time frame chart, one of these
more smaller swings like Apple has had,
and you can make, let's say, $200
because you're risking 1 to2. Now, we'll
get into the math a little bit more
later, but essentially, you're able to
take advantage of those volatile moves
and get in with a very accurate spot
towards, let's say, the lows of a swing
and then get out at a very accurate spot
at, you know, a previous supply level
that you notice. This allows you to
drastically improve how much you can
potentially make. Now, when it comes to
investing, it's a lot more safer,
especially with larger amounts of money,
because theoretically to lose your
$1,000, the whole stock market has to
crash. And that is extremely unlikely.
And if it does, you probably have larger
problems than losing your $1,000 or
however much money you have in the stock
market. But when it comes to trading, on
every single trade, you can risk
something like five or 10% of your
account. And you can do this multiple
times per day. You can also lose five or
10% of your account in a single day. to
show you a quick example is the ability
that you have as a trader to jump in
here at the lows with a super accurate
entry and then with a larger trade, you
can capture a massive swing up where you
can make a few,000 in this trade was 20
or 30 minutes before it ended up closing
out for pretty much $3,000 and I was
risking about $600 on that trade. So,
when it comes to trading tools, what I
highly recommend you do is for getting
chart access, learning, practicing this,
get Ninja Trader. I've been using it for
over 5 years now. And I'll leave a link
in the description below or you can scan
this QR code. I recommend getting set up
right now so you can go along, look at
the charts that we're about to look at,
and start demo trading and practicing a
strategy that you're going to be
learning. Now, the next thing for
setting up is what asset or market
you're going to look to trade. There are
so many options out there. And with my
experience of really going through all
of them, futures trading is the best
thing to do for starting a small account
and scaling it. It allows you to have
simple entry and exit styles. You know,
if you look to trade options or other
more complex markets, those are a lot
more tricky when it comes to just
saying, "Hey, I like this spot. I want
to buy. And so futures are really simple
for that. You are trading the major
markets in terms of like the S&P 500
futures, assets like oil or gold. And
I've always found those to be a lot more
reliable and consistent for trading,
which is really important when it comes
to being consistently profitable over
the long run. Having crazy volatile
penny stocks or cryptocurrencies makes
it a little bit harder in my opinion to
consistently get a feel for how the
market moves and make money over time.
And then the last thing is when I've
tried to trade forex, there's a lot of
funky fees involved, especially with
trading a small account. And then when
it comes to trying to trade stocks and
just buying shares of let's say Apple
and waiting it for it to go up and then
selling it when it's kind of between
those levels, you have run into
something called a pattern day trading
rule. What this essentially means is you
have to have $25,000 in your account to
be able to place day trades
consistently. And futures really allow
you to start with something as little as
$100 or $500 in your account. you can
start practicing demo trading and then
you can switch over which we'll talk
about in a minute and you're playing on
growing that account. Now once you have
Ninja Trader set up you're going to be
able to access the charts. I'm just on
their web-based platform right here.
It's super easy to access pretty much
anywhere. Initially I recommend opening
up a chart here and then just looking at
the ES futures. This is just the S&P
500. It's the main US stock market and
it doesn't really matter what you trade
at the end of the day. You know what I
just went over? That's my preference and
I suggest you doing it too. But when it
comes to analyzing charts, you can trade
any market you want. The analysis is all
the same because it's based on those
supply and demand moves that we were
talking about. The markets always
consistently bounce between supply and
demand levels no matter what you're
trading. And so you can easily place
trades based on those. Now, when it
comes to reading candlesticks, it's
pretty basic. The whole idea of why you
have them over just a basic line chart
is they give you more information.
Essentially, a red one is telling you
that the price essentially went up over
that candlestick and a red one is
telling you that the price went down
over that candlestick. So for a green
candlestick, you have the body or the
main colored green box. And that
essentially tells you that the price
opened here and closed here. And then
the line above it or the wicks is where
the price moved between the open and the
close. And so essentially what that
could look like, what the price could
have happened is it could have opened up
here, sold off, punched higher to the
high of that candlestick and then come
at the close and that would have created
that candlestick. Same thing for a red
candlestick but on the flip side is the
price actually opened here, probably
moved up to this high, sold off, and
then eventually came and closed at the
closing price. And so that's how all
these candlesticks work is you can look
at them and they'll all give you an idea
of what is going on a kind of underneath
the hood and a little more data. You
know, this one says, hey, the market
opened up right here, went all the way
up here and then closed right here. So
that is a really bullish candlestick.
Bullish just means that the price moved
up. And bearish means that the price
moved down over that candlestick. And so
it might seem like a lot of information
that you can't really tell what these
patterns mean initially, but what you'll
eventually realize over time is they
just help you understand more of what's
going on. And so the biggest thing
initially is you don't need to be paying
attention to these smaller patterns that
are created. What I have found over time
is it's actually better to pay attention
to the bigger picture. And that's what
you can start to make with these
candlesticks is you can start to say and
look at okay where are the big swings in
the market and where is it showing that
it's kind of choppy. And basically how
you can see that is with how these
candlesticks look is right here. These
candlesticks are showing you there's a
lot of bearish movement to the downside
in one direction. a lot of volatility
and then a lot of the times, well, you
can see on the flip side, it had to
reverse that volatility because there
was supply and demand imbalance. And so
there all of a sudden was a ton of
supply, people wanting to sell, and then
all of a sudden there was a ton of
people saying, "Hey, I actually like
this level where this price is at and I
want to buy it." Versus compared to
these candlesticks here, they're really
choppy. essentially just saying that
they're all just kind of off back and
forth essentially over all these
candlesticks is the price went nowhere.
You know, again, showing that supply and
demand equilibrium. And this is not a
spot where you want to be placing
trades. And so that's why it's really
important to be zooming out and looking
at the big picture of seeing, okay,
where is the supply? Where is the
demand? Where are the essentially the
extremes in the market that actually
look like good selling or buying
opportunities to place a trade? That is
the whole tricky part of trading is
being able to understand and look at a
chart, wait for those areas where it's
maybe in a supply level or in a demand
level and place a trade on that and then
avoiding these areas in the middle of
those supply and demand levels where
it's a lot harder to know what
something's going to do. Patience is
probably one of the number one factors
when it comes to trading and allowing
yourself to have consistent
profitability over the long run. And so
I'll leave a link to a video that
explains way more on technical analysis
and understanding charts than we do
here. But the next biggest thing that
when it comes to trading is you have to
learn how to accept losses. They are
just a part of the game and a part of
the process. And probably one of the
most important things about trading is
the mental side of trading and being
able to understand that losses are a
part of the game. And you have to be
more focused on the math of it and the
whole goal of consistently over time
making more money than you're losing. So
to illustrate this a little more with
some math, let's say you're trading and
you lose $100 every trade, but every
time you win, you're trying to go for,
let's say, three times your risk. So
you're looking for $300 a win on
average. So let's say over 10 trades you
have here that you have seven losses
over here and you have three winners.
But the winners because you're kind of
going with these swings, you are winning
more than you're losing. Well, what this
comes out to is, you know, total you're
losing $600 over those 10 trades, but
your average loss is $100 and then you
made $850 over those three wins because
they were larger wins and your average
win was close to three times your risk.
Well, if you take your total profit loss
between those 10 trades, well, you were
actually positive 250 overall. And the
highlight here is that you had a 70%
loss rate. Even though you are losing a
majority of these trades because of the
math and how you've set things up, you
are still consistently profitable over
those 10 trades. That's the whole reason
why you can't get married to one trade.
You can't actually, one of the biggest
mistakes people do is they will make
their losses larger. They'll say, "I'm
going to risk $100 on this trade." they
put their stop loss at a certain spot
and then they actually move that stop
loss farther away increasing their risk
to let's say 150 and what that does is
it messes up the math and it makes it so
they aren't consistently profitable over
the long run and what you have to
realize is you don't know the outcome of
any trade no matter how good one trade
looks it could totally become a loss now
if I pull up the actual Ninja Trader
platform if you get Ninja Trader I
highly recommend using that instead of
the web-based version just because it's
a lot more powerful. Now, to go into
some basics of technical analysis and
chart reading that is super important
for your trading. First off, you want to
think about time frames. If I quickly
look at, let's say, a 30inut chart, you
can see that over a couple days, there
are a few candlesticks made. You know,
if you have a daily chart, that means
there is one candlestick per day. And
this is saying it's a 30-inut chart. So
there are a lot more candlesticks with
one made every 30 minutes. And so what
this allows you to do is it allows you
to either see a bigger picture if you
want to kind of zoom out and see what
the market's doing or if you want to
zoom in to what's happening right now.
And even though you can see on a 30-inut
chart, this just looks like chop back
and forth. But if I go into a one minute
chart now and kind of zoom out to
essentially showing that small section,
you can see there's a lot more back and
forth and potential trade opportunities.
And so this is why it's important to
realize that you can trade on a smaller
time frame if you want something a
little more fast-paced, or you can trade
on a larger time frame if you want
something slower that plays out more
over time and multiple days or weeks.
But the biggest thing when it comes to
looking at these charts is looking at
essentially the big picture and the
structure. Knowing and understanding the
structure of what is going on really
will help you paint a picture and
understand what's going on. And so
generally, you know, you have your
basics of an uptrend is made by higher
highs and higher lows. And then a
sideways trend is essentially where the
highs and the lows are roughly the same.
They don't have to be perfectly, you
know, at the exact level. And then a
downtrend is signified where the market
is starting to make lower lows and lower
highs where consistently over time it's
moving lower. Now, this can depend on
what time frame you're looking at as
well. And so just because you are
looking at a let's say 30 minute chart
where the market is clearly in an
uptrend well that doesn't mean you can't
go into a one minute chart and say hey I
think you know because the market's come
up here and made kind of a triple top
that I don't think I can make money and
bet that the market's going to go down
and have a small downtrend on the one
minute chart. And so don't get, you
know, a biased based on a larger time
frame if you're really looking to trade
at a smaller time frame because the
larger time frame trend doesn't
necessarily matter. Now, a couple of
other important things is drawing supply
and demand levels. I like to look at a
bigger picture than what I'm trading.
And so, if I'm trading on this one
minute chart right here, I'm looking to
enter in trades. What I want to do is I
like to look at a 15-minute chart or a
30-inut chart to see, okay, where are
the major swings and where essentially
the supply and demand zones might be.
What I like to do is essentially stick
to the extremes. You can see this is
still in a pretty tight range here, but
over the last kind of 24 hours over this
section is the market's been essentially
pingponging between these highs and
lows. And so what I want to do is then
if I go into a one minute chart and I'll
actually draw these on the chart so they
will transfer to the one minute chart
when I zoom in is anytime the market
comes up to this either supply zone or
resistance zone or down to this support
level or demand zone. I want to look to
buy down here and sell up here. And so
what you can do now knowing where those
zones are is you can just again look at
the basics of reading the candlesticks
of saying, "Okay, the market's in an
uptrend here. It's making higher highs
and higher lows. And so it's in an
uptrend and I'm not going to look to
essentially bet that it's going to go
lower. You can make money either
direction. I actually generally make
more money betting that the market's
going to go down. But the whole idea is,
okay, as this starts to go sideways here
and go into more of a sideways trend,
without trying to really look at the
candlesticks, you can see that it's gone
in a clear uptrend to now going
sideways. And so based on that, well,
you can say, okay, it's losing steam
here at this resistance zone. And so
it's likely based on just those two
factors that it could start to shift
lower. And so that's how you start to
understand and read the potentials of
what the market can do. Now, that
doesn't necessarily mean it's going to
sell off, right? Again, it's all part of
the math of it and saying, "Okay, I'm
going to use, let's say, these two
signals to say I think the market's
going to go down and I'm going to bet
that it's going to go down." And that
doesn't necessarily mean it is going to.
It could sit here for a while with that
kind of equilibrium and then all of a
sudden demand could pick back up and it
could keep going higher. And so that's
why you have to keep that math in play
so that when you're wrong, it's not a
big deal, but when you're right, you're
able to capture a nice swing down and
profit to offset your losses and make a
little extra. Now, let me lay out a road
map for you to start on this journey to
getting to a real money trading account.
The whole idea is on this road map, you
know, you're starting out learning,
studying, and what you want to do next
is you want to then develop a strategy.
My advice is keep it simple. You can see
I just went over a simple idea of how
you can kind of see where the market's
going based on super simple factors. The
funny thing about trading and the
markets is it seems like it can be
really complicated and it can but it can
also be really really simple. The
complicated part about it is actually
consistently executing your strategy day
in and day out. And so that's why I
highly suggest demo trading using
something like Ninja Trader because it's
going to allow you to kind of get
started, understand charts, understand
really how trading works without losing
money. Because in trading, mistakes lose
you money. And then when you've been
consistent for multiple months, because
the market has cycles, times where it's
super volatile and times where it's
really good for trading, and then times
where it's really flat, choppy, nothing
going on, and it's really easy to blow
your account because you're used to a
super volatile environment. And it only
takes time to really know that you can
handle those. And then switch to a real
money account. Now, this is just a super
quick trading road map. I have actually
created a whole multi-page PDF that you
can get for free that lays out you a
90-day roadmap of something that you can
do and focus on every day over the next
90 days while you're going in to this
trading journey. It's going to have a
ton more resources, tips, and helpful
suggestions that will keep your trading
on the right track and keep you away
from wasting 5 years like I did. Now, if
you want a strategy that has worked for
a ton of other people who have tried it
out, check this video out right here.
It'll give you a stepbystep process. And
if you want to get Ninja Trader, you can
check it out right here. And make sure
to get that 90-day road map as well in
the description below.